three two one here we go
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome to yet another winners on a
wednesday and i want to introduce you to
a lady called anne hubbard she's got two
renter rents
making her a clean profit of 2 000
pounds per month
so in this video i'm gonna be picking
her brain
asking her exactly how she did it so
that you
can do the exact same thing too don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
smash the like button and thank you so
much for coming to my home
thank you so much for the invitation
thank you so you have got two rents and
rents
yes making 2 000 pounds a month so
massive congratulations
where did this all start like how did
you even get into property in the first
place
uh my mom had uh a block of flats
yeah in kenya and i really loved
watching her just manage that and uh you
know look after our tenants and
so inspired from that uh
was just amazing and i was in kenya yeah
okay so your mom had a block of
flats in kenya yeah was making good
money yeah
sustaining her in her retirement so
fantastic
yeah and did you grow up in kenya yeah i
was born and raised in kenya
okay so then what happened next then uh
moved to america when i was about
21 and uh
we went there to study i was studying
fashion design
maybe you can cut that one out but went
to study
and uh went through school there
met my husband second year and
yeah we've been married ever since and
your husband by the way is an incredible
guy
yeah american you guys got married and
it was him that actually signed you up
for
the training with myself which we're on
to so okay so grew up in kenya
moved to america to do studies how did
you end up in the uk
curiosity uh we we would stop
in the uk on our way to kenya because my
sisters live here
yeah so we'd always stop here see a bit
of england
carry on to kenya on the way back do the
dip again in england
and then off to chicago okay we always
uh so one year we thought oh this is
interesting maybe we can live there for
a bit and just
see how that feels uh so we did
great and you stayed here you obviously
like it
yeah we've been here 10 years now 10 and
a half uh
we do love it the kids are growing up
well
um and it's it's been really wonderful
okay
so you um in england
married what are you doing so when we
like first met when you connected what
what what are you doing for a job and
stuff uh i was working for
a pharmaceutical company yeah uh and
uh i was an analyst for them uh so
making sure the drugs are in
on time yeah to save and sustain a life
as
their logo goes yes and are you still
doing that
no what do you do now full time in
property full time in property
amazing so what people want to know
today
is they want to know how you went from
working full-time
in a pharmaceutical company to having
more free time
and literally being able to quit your
work
from two properties that you do not even
own
yeah and you don't feel like it's a
massive deal i don't feel like it's a
huge deal because uh you know obviously
when you see other people doing
so much you aspire to be to reach those
heights
so i'm still barely scratching the side
but generally speaking
what qualifies you to be on winners on a
wednesday is if you're making 2 000
pounds a month in recurring property
income
then in your full-time property then
that that's great and to you it doesn't
seem like a big deal because you're on
the academy
and you can see other people that are
doing like 10 grand 20 grand
like crazy amounts but actually to a lot
of people
being able to escape out of their job
it's it's a it's a massive it's a
massive deal
so why don't you start by telling me how
did you choose
rent to rent as a strategy uh i came for
the
rent to rent uh event back in 2020
just the beginning of the year uh and so
that was interesting
thinking about should we go for an essay
or should we go for
a more you know bigger more stable
income
although the essay would have been
amazing to have but
now in hindsight i think going just
during the pandemic
hmo is more stable right than
than having an essay at the moment so
tell me what is
what does rendering mean it just means
taking someone's property increasing the
value
in terms of you know the experience for
the tenant
and really making it uh a wonderful
home for them especially if the landlord
isn't able to bring it
up and or is tired of managing the
tenants
so it can be solution for people who are
going through different things in their
lives
um so in in my case the landlord was
an older lovely gentleman who during the
pandemic was stuck in india
and he had done up the property it had
been vacant for two years prior
he had had really bad experiences with
tenants before
it being vacant for the two years thank
you for two
years yeah yeah really and uh
when he did it up he was thinking okay
should i lent
give it to the council to put their
tenants in but
from his previous experiences it had
just gone south very quickly
okay so that's the ultimate example of a
tired landlord
yeah really like just do your thing
just give me my guaranteed rent was he
living in india
uh he has businesses uh in kenya and
uganda and he's got so he's a bit of an
international
where's his home though he lives here
okay yeah where's the property
in northampton and where are you based
in northampton right so you're really
close to the property yeah i also love
when i asked you about what rent to rent
was
straight away the way you explained it
was all about how you add value what the
service is rather than saying
no if you if you said to most people
what's rent to rent you'd say it's where
you give the landlord
the smallest rent you can and then you
push the value up and you keep the
profit in between yeah like that's one
yeah but but you didn't say that you
said
it's when you find a landlord you might
be struggling or tired
and then when you improve the house and
maybe when the landlord can't and
turn into a great home yeah you really
focusing on the solution
and and we we want to really have a
fantastic relationship with this
landlord
uh he he is he's really a really
good family everything is wonderful
about him
we call each other just to chitchat uh
it's really been good for both of us
yeah so it's a pure win-win why would
the landlord let you
make how much you making on that first
property that's 900
nine nearly nearly a thousand on that
one okay so between nine and ten hundred
pound a month
why would the landlord not just do that
himself
uh because he has done it before and his
experience wasn't good
i'm not sure maybe what he was
attracting the tenants that he was
having come in uh the solutions that he
was looking at was using
having the council bringing tenants uh
you know for them to give him a
sustainable
monthly income right so uh
by us coming in and really giving him a
really good solution the house is kept
up
the tenants are wonderful
you get to choose really good ones
so it's been a really good experience so
far
now i want to know as well because you
mentioned you're on the rent to rent
course with me
on the beginning of beginning of yeah
2020.
okay yeah early 2020. now back end of
2019
was when i met your husband at the deal
finding extravaganza
tell me the story of what happened so he
i had signed up to go
actually uh and then because i wanted
him to know
you know things about property because
i'm so into it it's
i love property i'm always like
you know even when i'm watching tv i'm
like in the background i'm never even
like focused really on the story but
uh so it was a good opportunity for him
to really get to know what it is i'm up
to
uh but at the same time
you know because he he wanted to support
me uh in what i'm doing
yeah so he went for the dfa and then on
that
second night i think uh he called me
about
10 o'clock and he's like i've signed you
up for the academy
and i'm thinking okay and
very supportive husband yeah so it was
like okay
you're gonna do it i've signed you up
everything's good to go
and it's because i was sleepy the kids
are asleep i'm thinking what
it's really late okay you could have
waited to come home and tell me
all about it but you know you need to
speak to chris and get this sorted out
and it's
that's incredible because a lot of
partners and i know your husband is
you know what what is it that he does
what's his boss's business he used to
build and uh design pipe organs for
cathedrals right because all i remember
is when i met him
at the deal finding extravaganza he said
look i've come here
kind of on behalf of my wife i'm
interested in property but she's the
person that's really going to make this
work because she's got the time and the
inclination
i'm really busy but i said to him well
let's get you
let's get your wife on the academy so he
agreed he thought was a good idea
yeah he signed you up for the academy um
but you were going to be the person that
really kind of spearheaded the property
the property business
um and then it was literally just a
matter of months before you got your
first property
yeah we uh there was one we had gotten
in coventry
and uh that was uh around july yeah
and we you know how you really want it
to work but the numbers are saying no
you can't work and you're like
really willing it but really it would
have been a really bad deal
it would have been a really bad decision
we wouldn't have been helping the
the guy you know the owner because we
would have
not succeeded on that end that's really
interesting again your words like the
way you say we wouldn't have been
helping him because
it wouldn't have worked there's got to
be money in it for you
in order for you to be able to offer the
service yeah and uh
remember it's a two-way street yeah
because
it's uh you're helping the the owner
and you're also supporting your family
and yourself
so it has to go both ways so if we had
taken it on
we would have we wouldn't have been
happy with
the income and we wouldn't have been
knowing myself i wouldn't have been able
to put pressure on the
on the landlord for him to accept a
lower rate just because i want to make
some
change on it so it wouldn't have been a
win-win taught me through that first
deal
how did you find the owner
on gumtree on gumtree interesting
what did you say on gumtree so i wrote a
little note
on gumtree and i said
would you accept a three to five year
lease on your property
as a corporate lent yeah and that was it
simple straight to the point because i
didn't want to
fluff about and you know yeah i didn't
want to
i just wanted to straight and so the guy
sent a message and normally i would
send messages in late at night on
gumtree just watching tv just sending
those
one by one and so he wrote back
and i'm like wow it's really late at
night he wrote back and said i'll call
you at 9am
so 9am he called and he was like this is
great
the guy wants a corporate let and so
because he was an agent in between us
and we agreed
so uh he we had agreed the price
what it would be and we're like happy to
proceed can we see it
we went and saw it it was beautiful and
you know during the pandemi it was
because we didn't have all this
information about you know how the
transmission happened or whatever it is
about
the disease how it happens so going to
see the place uh you know how the
it was awkward going in walking into a
house with a stranger and you're like
scurvy season um anyway we went
looked at it it was just beautiful he
had gutted everything
uh he had put in beds uh
wardrobe uh very simple very clean
um and we we were like wow we could
really like make this
uh homely and and lovely so
the agent what does he get out of this
i think he got a finder's fee right so
the aim
the agent's job is to just find a tenant
yeah and they're gonna get paid by the
landlord and the agent found
you so he got his one-off fee he got his
one or three
which he was happy with he listed it on
gumtree but then you
are how much did you agree to pay the
landlord a month one month
uh 2 000. wow a lot of money yeah yeah
so 2 pounds a month and
i mean that's not bad that sounds like a
reasonable amount of rent were you
scared that you'd be committing to
paying two thousand pounds a month
and then you couldn't get tenants uh no
because we had uh
run the numbers and not just running the
numbers we had checked
uh to to make sure that there's demand
so
we won how do you do that how do you do
the due diligence uh
so you have to go on spare room uh
check if these people looking for
uh properties that are or rentals that
are
above a certain amount yeah and we knew
we could charge that high figure
right so you did thorough due diligence
yeah and then
i think sometimes people say i'm nervous
i'm scared and i think you should be
because you don't know what you're doing
especially because it was well remember
the first one
we really wanted it to work but the
numbers were saying you can't work so we
had that little experience of having a
deal not
not work yeah so the second one was uh
okay
we've learnt so now we need to make sure
that we feel good and we're happy and
you know all the parties are fine yeah
how soon after
the rent to rent training did you find
the coventry property deal
uh so that was in july
okay so a few months yeah and then when
did you secure the northampton one
uh the following month august august
but we didn't sign until september the
15th
is when the actual document i think i
remember you getting that actually i
think i remember you
we spoke we spoke about it and i
remember saying oh man i want to come
around and see it and you were like well
i'm a bit scared about that yeah yeah
this was that
yeah yeah you're a much more cool calm
and collective yeah i was like oh i
don't know
because i need to feel it fast you
wanted to fill it and you wanted to
so talk to me about that you're paying 2
000 pounds to landlord are you also
having to pay for bills and stuff
yeah yeah so it's a lot of financial
commitment it is yeah
also financially like where were you at
the time if you couldn't have rented it
would that have crippled you or were you
in a really good place where were you at
uh we were in a really good place
actually uh
one of the benefits of uh being in the
academy is
knowing like you can raise finance okay
so this deal was actually
uh supported by raised finance
one of my husband's colleagues his mom
was looking
to invest money because in the bank
she's not getting
really what she deserves to be getting
yeah
so that was a really good so they put
the money in they put the money in
and uh my daughter also gave us some
money
oh no and uh we signed a contract and
every month to give her
interest on her commitment very good
it's really uh yeah
so for you it was a no money down deal
yeah basically yeah yeah but rental rent
doesn't need
masses of money anyway no it's just
normally the deposit
maybe some furniture a few things you
said the property was already in a good
state how much money was needed to put
down
uh so we put down the 2000 deposit and
then the first month's rent
yeah uh and then we did
uh the furnishings so in total if we're
not counting the deposit
it was about 4 000 yeah yeah so not
crazy money
not crazy money but uh good enough to
sort of yeah it's enough to put some
people off
yeah bear in mind you'd already invested
in training now you're investing in
the rent to rent it's quite a lot of
money to put down now yet as you said
you learned the skills on the academy of
raising finance and how
yeah which you used but still it's quite
a risk
a lot of people in your situation would
have been quite worried and i think
that's where
what i was just saying people are
usually worried when they don't know
what they're doing
when you know what you're doing you can
be more confident yeah
yeah and the condition of the house was
a big plus we didn't need to come in and
do carpets do the interlinked fights
we didn't it was a full-fledged hmo you
knew what you were doing did you have a
break laws in place
yes it's a six month right so worst case
after six months
you could walk away yeah so what
happened then so you got the keys
what happened next so we got the keys so
the so this was
absolutely bonkers so we got the keys
before we signed the contract
and so we got furnishings we got you
know decorated a room
get it uh show ready you know for the
tenants to come and see
and so we actually had 10 you know
before you signed the contract you're
like you want to start marketing already
yeah before yeah so that when the time
comes
it's exactly yeah so we got the keys the
tenants came in so we got two really
interested ones and we're like okay fine
and then um later on we've come to find
that the
landlord had three agents working for
him to find this property oh no
so we were thinking okay
so what's happening uh one agent was
telling him
you have to give them a commercial lease
they have to pay six
months up front and not just pay six
months up front
it has to be fully ensuring
fra fully uh whatever that lease is
anyway they wanted all kinds of extra
stuff extra
and were thinking wow you want like more
than six grand
up front we're not ready
to even like think about that at this
time so what happened
it fell through so we had to give back
the key
no because we weren't going to give him
all that money up front
yeah you know we know it's a good deal
but not in that kind of dimension
you know yeah so we just we
it was i remember calling alice there
and say okay
this is not happening my deal is falling
through what should i do to
save it is like uh then he had me call
ricky and
ricky was like and let me just be
straight it's not a good deal
i was like okay okay so come on is this
the deal in northampton
yeah so it fell through it fell through
yeah and then what happened
so uh a week or two after because we
have
tenants now right they've come to see
they sound stressful
it was crazy so i sent a message to the
landlord
we were in touch at this time and i said
listen i've got two tenants
whoever is managing your property it's
really nice they love it
do you want them i wasn't going to
charge him a finest fee or anywhere
i was like do you want it do you want
the two tenants and
he was like what you're giving me
tenants after everything's falling flat
yeah and uh so he said okay
and then jeff suggested uh to ask him if
he
understood what we were offering and so
i wrote to him and said did you
understand that we're offering you a
guaranteed rent for this match and this
match
we're going to take over the bills you
won't have anything to worry about you
just sit back and
you know wait for your monthly check and
he's like no i didn't know that
and thought what okay so that's what
we're offering
and a week later he was like okay fine
i've been i'll be in the uk finally i
can fly over
you know and we can sign it then wow
yeah so what's the lesson in that
uh a no is never a no yeah
uh be generous you know uh
be open and honest in whatever you're
doing yeah
um yeah so true and also the fact that
you
gave so much value yeah you
tried to help you tried to serve
before getting a deal you put a
relationship over
money yeah and then the money follows
yeah
which is the absolute core of what we
teach on the academy
so and it's you it fits with your nature
it it does because i wouldn't want to do
it any other way no
yeah so some people that would have
tried to go in and get the deal
what happened to the agent in the end
did they feel silly
no because they i don't think maybe they
didn't uh understood because i think
they were competing with each other the
agents because they knew each other
you just went straight to the landlord
directly
boom got the deal yeah okay great so
then
once you've got the deal you've got the
keys got the contracts you're paying the
landlord
2 000 pounds a month what happened next
who now newly find the tenants you know
dress it up
and the tenants came and you know
it's a new experience looking for
tenants actually because
i'd never looked for tenants before uh
but you know you meet people and you
sort of
do in jail do we not yeah you know how
is it because it's a bit of a
long-termish
relationship yeah so yeah going through
tenants and really checking them out
and as you say having a empty room is
better than having a bad tenant in it
correct correct you're better off to
have no tenant than a bad tenant
yeah how long did it take you to fill
the house uh it took us
december is when we had the last one in
so how long was that since when you got
the contract signed so
september to december is the last room
but
uh we filled it out one by one all the
way to the end
right yeah and then were you were you
ever a
loss during those months or did you
manage to break even oh yeah we managed
to break even
okay so you broke even then you stopped
making a bit of profit then a bit more
profit
and then the house was full yeah are
those tenants still there now
uh no actually one of them got covered
unfortunately and so caused the others
to stay home
and uh with that we lost one who said i
can't stay because he needs his support
bubble
like yeah yes you know whatever you need
for your good life just go do it quickly
yeah
so he wanted to leave after his uh
before his tenancy ended and we were
fine with it because we can't hold
anyone hostage we want to
yeah so one moved out did you did you
just replaced him we yeah we were just
waiting to replace him now
apart from that they're all still apart
from that one
other because she was a student we had
one student in the house
and so when she left uh
we got someone just instantly back in
how many rooms are there
six six so you're making
sorry how much profit are you making a
month 9 27
927 yeah and is that after all your
maintenance voids
costs everything that's how much you're
left with profit yeah that's great
yeah for the first deal yeah yeah and
then you went and got another deal
so that one was born out of the fast one
right so one of the agents who was
working with the landlords
he was doing his hmo application for him
so he came to the house to look at it
because he um
just to make sure that things are fine
or whatever he needed for his paperwork
and he really liked what we were doing
with the place and he said oh i've got
another one do you want it
and we've got what yes you know what
it's like
one gumtree message
one and now you've got two rent to rent
how much profit is the second um second
property it's going to be just over a
thousand
just over a thousand so one's just under
a thousand once it's over a thousand
yeah so two thousand pounds a month from
one
gumtree message yeah
i mean it's crazy yeah what have been
the key lessons
throughout the last year on the academy
and getting these rent events
it's it's been a journey you know the
the disappointments and then
things working out and uh yeah like you
say discipline your disappointment
yeah yeah some days you call the agents
and it it doesn't work it
you know but you just keep yeah keep
going when did you quit work
december 31st was my last day and was
that back into last year
yeah and how did that happen talk to me
about what happened uh
i was really stressed at work uh and
trying to think about property i didn't
really have the mental space to think
about property
because i was working for a
pharmaceutical company so
the demand for drugs during coved
was mental yeah so
i just couldn't bear it anymore because
since covey began
a year yesterday when you started
working from home
it was you on it
a hundred and ten percent every single
day some nights up to three a.m
really long hours and i just had to
go do my life as hard as i'm doing that
life
yeah is how i felt about it what do you
mean by that because you work so
so hard you work so hard at your job
and then you forget to work so hard for
what you really really want
which is what you you know your true
calling for me
personally that was that is this is my
true
calling it's almost like if you work on
your business as hard as most people
work on their job
yeah because most people spend so much
time trying to
build someone else's thing but you've
spent
part-time on top of your job
during the academy yeah you've got two
deals
that have now meant that you can go
full-time into property yeah which is
which is incredible what's next
what's next for ann herbard so there's
uh the agent has
two other properties two other eight
beds because the second one is an eight
bed house
yeah and it's got two others attached to
it that
are in great condition and we're hoping
to get those two as well
and uh i'm setting up the deal sourcing
side of things
incredible so i can kick start that so
this is just the beginning for you
this is really the beginning yeah and
it's interesting as well because the
academy is obviously a 12-month
training program but it's not a case of
like when you go to university and then
when you finish
hopefully you're going to get a job
hopefully you're going to make some
money the academy it's a case of doing
it alongside the training
which is what you've done yeah you've
now it's been 12 months which is great
but of course you know what it's like
once you're part of the family
you kind of always are yeah what's your
experience being like with the training
what was it like what happened uh it's
been great actually
there's a lot to discover you know with
property i think
once you go through the training and
then you have to go find the depth of
which
where you want to be so there's a lot of
discoveries
there's a lot of unknowns obviously
because nobody teaches you about
property at school
yeah so there's uh really big gaps to be
filled
to be able to be really successful
there's a lot to learn
and having the academy members just uh
you can bounce off ideas or people are
asking questions on the text and you can
you know sort of fill them in with what
you know and then they can fill in
with what they know it's really it
becomes a
good environment to gel with different
people who
are you know doing different things than
you are and really inspiring
how's life changed now than say one year
ago
oh yeah it's it's it's a load of
coming from being trained to be an
employee
and now being self-employed and really
just doing your thing
successfully yeah yeah yeah what does
your husband jeff what does he make of
all of this because i know he was the
person that
really championed you at the beginning
yeah what does he make of what you've
done
uh he loves it we're doing it together
now that's great
yeah yeah final piece of advice to
someone watching this
thinking i'm really inspired and he's
amazing
and i want to follow in the footsteps of
a hand and i want to start getting my
first properties
i want to become full-time in property i
want to be successful
starting with maybe not lots and lots of
money what will be your best top tips
for them to get started
do something yeah do something and
find someone who has done what you're up
to and ask them
and go everywhere to get any information
you can
to really get that desired fulfilled
incredible well hey thank you for coming
down it's been a real
delight to hear your story thank you and
i'm really excited about seeing you go
and get more and more and more deals
you're a great person and you and your
husband deserve every success that
you've got
thanks so much for inviting me it's
really i know i'm
barely scratching the surface but i'm
really inspired to do more
that's great yeah hey guys i think
you'll agree it was an incredible story
what she's done what she's achieved in a
short amount of time
starting with using other people's money
making two thousand pounds a month
from properties that she doesn't even
own it's pretty admirable
so drop a like drop a comment every
single week i interview another student
that's become successful and have their
lives transformed
through property if you want to see more
interviews like this
you can see a whole playlist where
there's over 100 right up here
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel where you can do that up here
and if you want to join me at the
property investors crash course where it
all starts
i'll leave a link in the description
below thanks so much see you next time
[Music]